we will on 9 March
2015 start purchasing Euro denominated
public sector Securities in a secondary
Market the combined monthly purchases of
public and
private will amount to 6
million they are intended to be carried
out until the end of September
2016 in any case Rec conducted until we
see a sustained adjustment in the path
of inflation which is consistent with
our aim of achieving inflation rates
below but close
to% over the medium the ring Ecom for on
the but have
diminished following recent monetary
policy decisions and the prices at this
point in time we see absolutely no
reason
to think or plan or act in any different
way from what we've planned namely
bil
201 Beyond if needed our monetary policy
decisions have worked and it's with some
certain degree of
satisfaction that the council has acked
this we see that the objectives are
gradually being
attained and the market reaction to the
announcement the expectation first and
the announcement second of our
Securities Market program it's also
being quite effctive